all right three one four yes sir all
right hey everybody this is gary vay
ner chuck and this is episode 314 of the
askgaryvee
show and i'm extremely excited to have
this guest
here i've seen some of noor's content on
the internet um
i actually don't know the backstory uh
which is what i usually do when i have
guests on so i'm gonna be hearing the
origin story of how
she has amassed this enormous attention
in
her region and all over the world and
more fun
we were just getting ready for the
episode last night in new york
there was really difficult summer
lightning thunder
uh weather and we were boats somewhere
else
and uh i drove from toronto to new york
for
nine hours last night and you drove from
michigan michigan to new york how long
was your drive
nine hours i love the thing we're so
symbiotic
on this friday nor why don't you tell
everybody your full name what you do
what you're about a little bit about
yourself and then we'll get into some
questions that everybody's watching live
start putting your phone numbers in and
what you want to ask about andy k
will take some questions i want to do a
little bit more questions that we've
been doing lately
okay so my name is noor stars once you
put a
mic to you because i've noticed people
have been is it like this
am i good now yeah i think probably just
a hint yeah hello
okay yes snore stars
my name is north stars i'm a youtuber i
started on youtube actually
uh 2014 when i first moved to the united
states
it was i was in high school and
actually i started uh sinan asked me
something about like
english did i learn it by myself when i
first moved to the united states my
english was
really um basic but basic and a very
early basic you know like i know bread
tomato how are you my name is lola yes
and you know where where did you grow up
where were you born so i was born iraq
yep and then we left from iraq to syria
as refugees yes
and then um i grew up like in syria and
then the war happened in syria we left
from syria to turkey as also our
refugees
i lived also in turkey for like a couple
of years and then we came to america as
a refugees
right so you're a triple refugee yeah
amazing you know
and uh you know i came to america as a
refugee
yeah and that's what that that's why
like i can relate to you when you talk
about like
starting from zero and coming to this
country you came here with your family
you started from
zero you worked so hard and look at you
now so that inspires me a lot gary and
that's why like
i'm here now because i love you a lot
thank you very much
i love you back so you come to the u.s
you're getting how
which you know you're young the whole
time but out of my own curiosity because
i'm so fascinated by this story
which was the biggest culture shock i
know you were young
all along but was the jump from
iraq to syria syria to turkey turkey to
the u.s what was the biggest
difference turkey from syria to turkey
from syria to turkey because
i was even more than turkey to u.s yes
go ahead
because turkey was very um shocking to
me it's a new language
yes it's not english i had to learn a
new language from
zero to communicate with people and i
was very young i
went to turkey when i was like 14 15ish
it was my first job there it was very
tough as a refugee yes it's literally
you have
you're by your own like by yourself you
know and i found myself
very responsible i mean in syria i was i
was very responsible
girl growing up because i grew up with a
single mom but in turkey it's like
my mom couldn't help me because she
doesn't know how to help me so it's like
i have to help everyone and that's
why it was the hardest america though i
was kind of
ready for it because i already learned a
lot in turkey so that what
that's why turkey is hardest it's really
cool yeah so you get here
and you go where uh first i want to see
seattle yep but not seattle like it's
small city around seattle washington
state
washington state yeah they usually when
you're a refugee they put you in like a
small
city yep just so exactly yeah
but it was it wasn't easy it was tough
so we moved to michigan because it has
more arabs and
my mom at least can like communicate so
i started in michigan high school
awesome and my english was
very basic and i love to talk gary
that's why i'm a youtuber
i feel like that's what helped me become
such a good youtuber because i fear
losing my voice more than dying yeah
right like if i couldn't talk that would
just be like
that's it we're done yeah i mean i'd
probably do some stephen hawking [ __ ]
and like figure it out but like
it would crush my soul yes i love to
talk i mean high school's already tough
to begin with for people that grow up
here
was like how was your michigan high
school experience
oh my god yeah as you said it's tough by
itself so imagine being in high school
without the language yes
and people talk and i'm like what are
you saying i want to understand like
what is this and i went to high school
with the mindset of
um like a middle eastern arab girl okay
so it's like
what is he saying no i see flirting
what's flirting i don't get it
so i was kind of aggressive and with no
language so it was it was a hard time
yes and i remember i went to my teacher
and i was like
look man like i need to speak he keep
teaching me like grammar
what what can i do with the grammar
grammar doesn't help me i know sentences
yeah i want to talk right i want to
speak and i'm like i need to speak i
want to talk to you
and he goes like you have to do extra
work i'm like i'm ready
give me the extra word like i [ __ ]
worked in turkey bro yeah like i want to
learn the language and he goes like
here like there's these websites and
listen to music and lyrics and movies
and
all of that and then youtube and he gave
me like something on youtube and that's
when i start like
binge watching youtube and i kind of
like i watch youtube before but not
focus watching youtube
and when i moved to america i had a lot
of free time like so i used it
i watched a lot and i remember i
remember the first youtuber and youtube
video that i watched for a youtuber that
made me like wait what is this exactly
it was uh for michelle phan you know
michelle phan yes of course she's one of
the uh
i met her last year in vidcon i waited
for her
and she came she's like hi and i i was
with the middle east team from like
facebook and
instagram and i'm like guys leave i'm
here for something and they were like
what's up and i
met her that's awesome and i'm like you
don't understand your video the spanish
makeup bread make i still remember the
video
that was the moment where i was like
that's so cool and i want to do that i
always wanted to do like
i always wanted to be in the
entertainment industry but everyone told
me it's impossible because i'm an arab
girl first of all yes i'm aware first of
all i'm aware of the political climate
in america so this is first of all not
only in america
just the culture you know it's hard for
a girl yeah like when i started youtube
girls were only showing their hands on
the internet you know
like rarely you see a girl with her face
so it's it's
in my culture yeah yeah it's hard like
now it's better now i see girls on
youtube and on social media and i'm like
wow
like it's really we we kind of like help
changing this mindset and we're still
like trying to
but like from all aspects it's like nor
impossible like go study like become a
doctor
you're good at school and i was really
good at school like um straight a
student
typical arab family but honestly i did
it for my mom because i want her to be
proud
of course so i always like get a's and
yeah become a doctor that's it
but that's not what i loved i didn't
want to so what happened next
you saw the michelle fan video yeah how
quickly before you made your first video
very quick the next day yeah literally i
made a video
and i remember looking at it and being
like oh my god i'm gonna put my face on
the internet
you know what i mean like i used to put
my face on facebook on private only
specific people see of course of course
it's cultural from that but you also
were recognizing that you were in a new
environment
in the u.s that did change it's like it
would have been far harder to do that
and i was so lonely gary yeah of course
honestly it was a lonely time for me
look you know listen i know you know my
content like a lot of the stuff i say
yeah you know
is counter to what parents and grown-ups
are assuming
yeah they they don't understand all the
benefits and virtues
of the digital landscape they focus on
negatives yeah
like they're like you know they don't
kids don't know how to talk to each
other
without using technology i'm like yes
but like what about you
sitting lonely in michigan in 1987 you
would have stayed [ __ ] lonely yeah i
was so lonely and like
very alone i was like no english yeah
and that's why i started in arabic
because i started singing yeah i started
in my life right i can do
and even though it was tough like i was
one of the first
girls on like youtube showing their
faces
and i remember thinking oh my god i'm
going to put this and
at the same time i was saying to myself
i can't always make it to bri
private yeah of course so it's not going
to you can go viral who's going to watch
it you know when you tell yourself he's
going to watch it
and then i i uploaded it and i went and
i came back and i saw
views and people commenting i got of
course i got hate from people saying
why is this girl here but also i got a
lot of girls supporting me and that's
what's shocking for me
it's like girls no we love you don't
stop we want you we want you to create
more videos
and i made my second video and i made my
third video and there was no money
i didn't know of course the money part
wasn't the
no i was in high school how how often
did you post at that point
not much when i first started like
once a month i don't remember but like
not once a month because i enjoyed it i
loved it so it's not
maybe more than that and i got to a
point where i was the first youtuber
like at least in the middle east that
was posting three times a week
and other youtubers like that was doing
youtube at the time
they were like why is this girl posting
because usually they post once a week
once every two weeks
and i'm like i love it i'm gonna post
more and more and that's when
i passed everyone like i start passing
people like that has big numbers
or like been on youtube for years and
i'm like boom
and then they text me i remember like
one youtuber he was like bigger than me
and i tried to like talk to him and he's
like
he didn't talk to me and then when i
passed him he contacted me he's like
what tags do you use for your video
and i'm like wait a minute tags what's
tags you know the tags that they you
know now i know but like i don't know
times back then i'm like
tags what's tags and then i googled
what's that like
because i didn't know he's like oh yeah
you must doing something i'm like
man i don't have money like they thought
you know i'm not even i don't have money
when i first started i don't have money
to do anything i'm just posting and
the the big misconception is quality
content yeah is
always underrated people always think
it's tactics and look
listen as somebody who won on not the
tactics
as i've built out capabilities whether
it's thumbnails or titles or
understanding
of course it's part of the equation but
the art is such a big part of the game
yeah and most people focus on the math
yeah and you were winning on the art
yeah just like i was creating content
that i really
love and enjoy and it was new to youtube
so people weren't like thinking it will
do well but i
did really good and what was new about
it like i would
just talk to the camera and like just
rant or tell them something that happens
to me
story but that wasn't the story time
time
but i was telling them story and they
loved it you know what uh
when did you switch from arabic to
english on your channel
i don't i don't make english videos you
don't know to this day to this day it's
only arabic yeah
have you've never made one have you
thought about it
i thought about it actually or you know
one of the things that i'm always
fascinated with a lot of the content at
vaynermedia you know obviously an
enormous latino population growing
and spanish speaking in america and for
a lot of brands we're doing spanglish
have you ever thought about doing a
video that mixes both languages
you know so at home when i speak with my
parents we'll start a
sentence in english and finish it in
russian yeah yeah yeah yeah
you'll start telling the story in russia
and you'll finish it in english or
you'll literally go back and forth
within mid-sentences
so like do you have you i think that i
think that's something worth debating
and if nothing else
if you think back to your earliest days
one of the things that very successful
youtubers
instagramers people that create content
get caught up in
is they know at this point of maturity
you're now five years later
you know what works yeah and
subconsciously you're at your most
least creative place because you're
maximizing on you knowing what worked
yet it was you knowing nothing in the
beginning that gave you the foundation
that's so true and i'm trying to
encourage more i i spoke at a youtube
off site
uh and it was all the you know it was a
crew of who's who yeah and i was like
the best thing all of you can do
is make a video tomorrow that you know
won't work
wow i like that yeah because you know
what we're
like i know if i'm making a video i know
it's going to get 5 million or 10
million
or 1 million you're subconsciously
already so close to it yeah
which is what's stopping you from making
an english video even though you should
do you think so you know many people
don't speak arabic i know a lot
yes i think so and i live in america
that's why people like
when i talk and more importantly like
there's so many girls like you guys
who want to see both yeah there's a 14
year old girl right now
in the in suburbs of london who
she's 14 and in her household the arabic
language has not been upheld
as much and she's 90 american
excuse me english speaking she has 10
nuance of arabic words
and she can't watch you because you talk
too fast and have too much of
a vocab and she doesn't understand no i
think i think
look i think both of us fought to be
here today
yeah i think no you never know why and i
and i appreciate you've always given me
a lot of love and have sent nice
messages and good vibes and stuff of
that nature but
i really genuinely think if anything you
producing
english or english arabic mix content on
youtube
asap is super important i i was thinking
of opening like an english channel
don't no try in my channel there's
nothing that's
what's listen you know this you know
that the five years ago girl knows this
yeah nothing's gonna happen on my
channel it's hard you know because like
it's arabic
some people don't speak english it's not
you're pandering to the current
viewership yeah
it's not hard if 88 of them can't
understand the english
yeah you're opening up yourself to the
rest of the world
yeah i'm just like because i worked
so hard for the channel do you genuinely
believe a singular video of you making
english
eliminates all you've worked hard with i
just posted a con
piece of content on my instagram an hour
ago that says i hate dogs
i have hundreds of people right now
actively replying in my comments saying
unfollow unfollow unfollow yeah i'm not
scared of that i'm trying to make a
point of more love with each other
yes it's not that i hate dogs though i'm
not the biggest fan of dogs i love
dogs gary well listen that's great i
love dogs
i love the new york jets i mean like
everyone's allowed to love different
things
my big point is though i posted it
and the team sent it to me and they
didn't even put an asterisk and they
didn't even like the way they wanted to
go about it
i would have really lost community
managing right now
but even the way i hedged it but what i
knew when i posted it is
if i can help one person become a kinder
person to another person
it's worth the thousands of people that
i lose yeah
you're looking at defense you're saying
to yourself i work so hard to do this
that if i do something in english i may
lose something
the algorithm subscribers some people
that don't want me to do english
yes what you're not thinking about is
all
the people that you'd be bringing in
yeah when you have nothing you have
nothing to lose
which is why you're most creative when
you have something
you lose your creativity because you
have something to lose
the words out of your mouth was i worked
so hard
yes i did actually and that's the thing
after reaching 10 millions gary
my goal was to reach 10 million and get
the diamond play button because i was
the first to get it in the middle east
okay
so people like even when we have events
with youtubers and i would tell them
i want the diamond play button they
would laugh at me because they're like
no one did it before you
and we don't know if that there's that
many channels in the middle east you
know
we're not i understand so they they
thought i'm crazy for a while
and i did it and i was so happy when i
received the diamond play button but
then after that
i had like um a period of time where i'm
like what's next
no that's because you're making too many
decisions on outside variables
like how easy i've never thought about a
single number
financially or youtube or subscribers
like or anything because the reason
you're not putting out a piece of
english content
is you're pandering something to the
outside
versus the only reason you have that
feeling of
emptiness or what's next or what's the
next goal whether it's good grades to
make your mom happy
whether it's subscribers whether it's
listen i love proving people wrong
like i can tell that you're very driven
by that that's a great thing yeah i love
that
that achieves a lot but at this point
if you're able to start changing it a
little bit
and make it about what you're trying to
accomplish
yeah what do you want to say how much
impact
do you listen if if you're if you want
to impact right yes
like like when you have this big of an
audience that you have right now
i'm sure you walk around knowing some
sort of feeling of a sense of
responsibility
definitely uh a sense of ambition
a sense of knowing wow i can really make
a difference
you're limiting yourself by not also
using
english since you're i wish i spoke all
these if i spoke mandarin
and i spoke arabic i'd be [ __ ] going
nuts
i'm actually trying to like i'm like i'm
like i'm like
devastated that i can't speak arabic
i was just in qatar the other day right
and i was like man i
like anytime when i'm in singapore like
i wish i could speak those languages
for the sole reason that i don't
transcribe
to all these channels so that i could
put it on my channel
here's why no one piece of content could
ever undo
all your hard work yeah
[Music]
see let's see
you have a point oh i'm aware i have a
point yeah
i'm curious about what's stopping you
see the thing is like i feel like i'm
under pressure
makes sense because like i represent the
middle east youtubers
which is amazing if i do it in english
then they might think that oh my god
like
she's leaving her culture how many how
many so listen
that makes so much sense to me yeah and
honestly
this was the first moment that i'm like
oh this is why she won
the fact that you're brave enough to
tell the truth right now yeah
already excites the [ __ ] out of me about
you thank you that makes a ton of sense
couple things there's a [ __ ] load of
people in the middle east who speak
english
too i know this because i don't speak
arabic and when i go there and i love
going there
i'm able to communicate with almost
every [ __ ] person
english is a uni is one of the universal
languages
yeah that's why i wanted to do english
content because i'm like i want to reach
everyone i want i want to be able to
speak to the world the other thing is
you're so young and have such a big
platform we need to be in a place where
we don't have to create separate
channels because we're scared of the
negative
we need to start creating we content
within our channels
so that we make things more inclusive
yeah
like you have such a big thing you speak
both
yeah and i speak some turkish i'm sure
you did so i was all pumped about it
yeah
like he was happy and he speaks a little
tie like and so i think you know like i
think
listen i can't encourage you enough to
try it
here's why you already know the right
answer
you remember your first video you
remember when you said to yourself
i could always make it private yeah you
could always not make another english
video on your arabic wow oh my god i
love that he's like you can't oh so try
it
you know what i'm gonna try it i believe
you i will i believe you
i will and i have a funny feeling it's
gonna be great and the same thing that
happened on your first video is gonna
happen
yes there will be hundreds of comments
of like [ __ ]
this you're selling out you're not
representing
and then you'll have a ton of people
yeah that tell you that this is huge
and amazing and you will impact and
bring more good to more people
i'll try it you will win the next game
the reason i've always won as an
entrepreneur
is i think in net score most people are
worried
about winning one to zero or losing one
to zero
i'm worried about winning 11 to six
yeah that's what we just talked about
everybody thinks it's one zero life is
not one zero
life is 11 to six yeah and that's what a
successful
navigator of the opportunity is in my
mind maybe that's why i drove nine hours
from michigan to here
i think so we want questions guys what
what else what
tell me the breakthrough video we're
gonna get some phone numbers right now
he's about to do a call but before we
get to this first call
everybody's got a break through video
see yeah was it the third video the 19th
the first
the 5 000 like when was the video that
was like oh [ __ ] like what was your
first
viral video it was actually school tips
school tips yeah i remember
it went like it was the first video that
hit like over a million
yeah and i'm like wait like a million
people what were you getting up to that
point
um a hundred thousand fifty times not
even a hundred thousand no
less sixties and thirties but the thing
about me gary which is like i
even didn't understand at the beginning
my numbers were like skyrocketing
yes like once people find me they they
subscribe and then
i passed everyone and i stayed number
one from 5 million till now
yes so that's i don't know like don't
don't ask me but like
well you you and the audience connect
with each other yeah i feel like my
audience
they know not everything about me mind
you i don't have draw my life video on
my channel yes of course
but they know some things that they like
we connect
yeah yeah anyway andy let's do the first
question
nora i really really really encourage
you to let me say this
i have a question yeah we'll get to it
we'll get to it uh
you shouldn't do good you shouldn't do
an english or an english arabic video
because i'm saying so
you should do it because you want to try
it and if you do want to try it then you
should do it
hello yeah hello who's this cody cody
yeah cody you're on with gary and noor
please say hello hey gary what's going
on man
thank you sandor how's it going hi how
are you what's your question good
yeah so um why i submitted a couple
questions but i guess i'll go with one
whatever you want
me yeah yeah so um i operate and own a
restaurant full time
and then also tomorrow me and a partner
are starting a
small business marketing agency so i
just want some
tips on you know staying motivated and
uh
being accountable for myself um so that
i can
do both businesses and be you know make
both both of them successful
sorry a little nervous no don't worry
cody uh
my question is the motivation part i
mean
why why wouldn't you be motivated is my
no no definitely yeah definitely
motivated but just i guess being
accountable and saying
are you are you worried about juggling
two things
that's more of it right 45 50 hours at
one job and then hopefully with a new
thing 20 to 25 hours a week
i mean it becomes it becomes actually as
long as just
yeah as long as that's a really good
point as long as you're staying look
when you're starting a new business
they're all productive i think people
don't understand that because
figuring out what isn't working is
almost as important as figuring out what
is working
because you don't know it's all new back
to being creative in the beginning with
videos
yeah so i think that that's keep that in
mind brother
that those 25 hours 20 hours are all
going to be valuable
because you're learning you've never
done client services for small
businesses
you understand number two i think as
long as you're healthy
and keeping yourself healthy and not
burning out from the sheer amount of
hours
then what you need to be figuring out is
how do you balance sleep
and escapism like do you need to watch
the ball game
how much fortnite do you need to play
what music do you need to listen to
there's kind of like there's kind of
like four there's to me it's kind of
like three pillars four here you've got
two businesses there are pillars then
there's your own kind of
health and happiness like do you get
enough exercise
sleep and rest and then the fourth one
is escapism like are you know a lot of
times when people listen to me they only
read the headline
i don't want you to not not watch
netflix i don't want you to watch
netflix if you're complaining and you're
unhappy
if you're happy like i watch the jets
every sunday
and there's nothing anyone could do
about it and i
garage sale and i spent three and a half
hours looking up sports cards last night
on ebay i need my escapism to make me
tick i'm just speaking to all the people
that aren't
happy when you're not happy you need to
judge your leisure
because when you're unhappy your leisure
is your escapism from your unhappiness
yeah right so a little background i uh
a year ago i had open heart surgery and
so once i recovered from that i kind of
got to the point where it's all the
stuff that i want to do i need to do it
now
you know yeah i mean open heart surgery
at a young age how old are you
right i'm i'm 31 right open-heart
surgery at 30
changes your perspective real [ __ ]
quick yes right right so i want to do
all this stuff
like my ultimate goal is to have a few
businesses by 2025.
hey cody your your ultimate goal has to
be being happy
yes right well that i think that's
that's it i enjoy storytelling and the
reason why i'm doing marketing is
you enjoy starting doing a lot more
marketing at the restaurant
you're talking to somebody who went
through it i thought i was building a
wine business
what i was building was a storytelling
platform that built a huge wine business
so i'm living what you're going through
let me just say this though
because one of the things that i've seen
from my friends
contemporaries and business associates
is when they have a near-death
experience or lose a very significant
loved one in their inner circle they put
this disproportionate amount of
short-term pressure on themselves
to get everything accomplished and i've
seen it become detrimental
at times so just be thoughtful of
it you know to me this is why the
process and the journey
and happiness need to be the pillars of
our society
as long as even opening the business is
the success
you are now playing with house money the
reason i'm so happy
is i think i play with house money just
being able to do
the things that i'm doing is what i want
to be doing not if they end up being
successful
yeah for sure yeah and i think right
and i enjoy the process too like
building of the business i think
and then building it to something like
just like you do is
is fascinating for me and then wanting
to build something else up again
right and i think that's why i want to
do the new thing because it's not the
not the restaurant's repetitive but you
know i enjoyed making it successful and
successful now
and then i want to take on something
another challenge it makes all the sense
of the world listen
i'm going to tell you something based on
everything we just talked about i would
just not judge yourself
i think you've got all the ingredients i
think if you're capable
over the next three years to not judge
yourself for example
it's going to be easier to get small
businesses to use you for marketing than
keeping them
because small businesses don't spend a
lot of dollars and it's hard to create
real tractional like roi
in the short term and you're gonna land
some clients pretty quickly off the
success of your restaurant
but then they're gonna fire you after
six months as long as you don't
then when you get fired by two clients
in a week look yourself in the mirror
and say i'm a failure
i wasn't able to keep two things going
at once as long as you're able to
really balance the judgment against
yourself
i have a feeling everything else i've
heard from you you're going to be in a
great spot it is the one
vulnerability the over judgment on
short-term
losses that are micro losses not macro
losses
right winning in the aggregate yeah yeah
yeah good nor anything to add or awkward
okay i appreciate it here you got it
cody take care let's go next question i
have a question go ahead you ask your
question
you know like i all i do is like create
yes that's what i know makes sense i
don't know like i
i try to study business and a lot of
people tell me you should have another
source of income i don't know
how does that work well what's another
source of income well listen you know
you can start unlimited products you
could start unlimited service you have
unlimited opportunities
you don't have to though this is what
makes me laugh about people
everybody thinks there's some sort of
blueprint
you don't have to first of all to your
point just
don't forget uh let's actually let's use
the both of us i
grew up always wanting to be a
businessman
it never ran through my mind that i
wanted to go to hollywood
i never joined the drama team i didn't
speak i got a d
in speech i got a d this is a report
card you've never
had i got a d in speech i'm legitimately
one of the
real speakers in society and i got a d
in speech
but i but the internet created a world
where i
became known so all the selfies and the
notoriety is not how i thought about it
so it makes sense that i know how to
build businesses because i honed my
skills in business
i always wanted to be business and this
became
a secondary thing for you you always
dreamed to be in hollywood
you wanted to be creative and a
personality or an actress or however you
thought about it
you aren't required to start a beauty
brand you aren't required to start a
fashion brand you aren't required
now you may want to because it might be
a fun new challenge
you're such a young woman you may wake
up in 10 years and say i want a new
challenge
you also may have somebody in your
circle or somebody from the outside
that you get to know over five years
that you say you want to go in business
with them
and he or she always wanted to start a
bottling water company
or a sneaker brand yes it's early for
you
really because i feel like the pressure
because i'm the oldest in the family
and i'm like responsible for a lot of
things let me ask you a question yeah
i have a funny feeling that your ad
revenue from youtube
is doing just fine yeah it's good it's
good
yes good and i have sponsorships i'm i'm
doing good but that's
what people say these are not guaranteed
you should open a business that's
guaranteed
and it's like i don't know what it's
just not true i don't know like what
else to do
they're wrong your business is not
guaranteed
yeah uh john wayne
was guaranteed me to be famous not
guaranteed to be a good businessman
yeah brad pitt is guaranteed to be
a famous person he's not guaranteed to
be a good businessman it's not smart
thinking
you may be capable of using the
awareness you have in your audience to
create
businesses you also might want to triple
down on being awesome with your audience
so that other businesses give you money
for sponsorship
do you many people have shifted to
selling t-shirts hoodies sneakers
candy makeup and are actually leaving
money on the table and they're doing it
for money
because now they're monetizing their
audience their audience has other
options to go so they're leaving them
their sponsorship dollars are going down
and they're not going to build a
successful bottled water company
wow that's why i you know i don't have
merch i never created merch
and people think i'm crazy for not doing
that and i was like i don't believe in
it
i don't want to create something and
people with newer stars
there are so many listen it's fun to
have the team here we everybody sees us
two cartoons
sneakers cereal like wine people are
like oh my god they do ever there are so
many things that we've been working on
for two years that never see the day of
life
yeah but it wasn't different you're like
this is your job you create
products it's it's what i love and it's
what i want to do but even within it if
i don't feel
where i'm going with it is if i don't
feel good about it even if i felt good
about it when we started
it i have to feel good from the moment
it's an idea in my head
to the moment you're loving it
tyler wanted to uh we were going to
release a t-shirt
gary was on board with it long story
short after four months we showed
g the shirt he's like yeah i'm not into
it we're not gonna do it yeah
tyler was just devastated
that's right and and because i live what
i preach when i tell somebody the losses
or the no's are as valuable as the s's
i pay tyler him spending four months on
that is money i've lost
yes like you know like like i don't
think people understand
my entire world listen one of the things
that i'm quickly
you know intuitively i wanted you here
but i'm quickly gaining insight to you
listen to me you're super young and i'm
gonna use my leverage of you looking up
to me right now
never ever ever do anything you don't
believe in it is the quickest
way to start the process of losing
everything you hold true
yeah that's my struggle now it's like i
don't want to it's not a true merch
i don't believe in it it's not a
struggle yeah it's not a struggle it's
hard sometimes to say no
it's very important it's like why this
is money you're leaving can i
can i rem let me give you a real good
one that i like to use when somebody
annoys me
that's close to me yeah once at a blue
moon
i if somebody's annoying me that i love
that i love who's trying to get me to do
something
i look them in the face and say you
become gary vee and you do it
oh that's nice so whoever's telling you
to do it you tell them
you go amass 10 million subscribers and
you do it yeah yeah
great job it's good it's good like once
in a blue moon if i get really good
rare but like like like an andy is close
enough to me now brandon my parent like
somebody really pushing me i'm like you
do it
yes oh my god i have another question
since you talked about
your loved ones yes what do you do for
your loved ones that don't understand
that you're
that busy they think you're just you're
faking it or you don't want to spend
time
with them when you're really busy but
they don't understand that how do you
deal with that because
i communicate with them how if they
don't get it by talking
well if they don't get it that's on them
that's not me yeah
yeah that's not my problem because like
you know how our life is busy and like
they don't get it like why do you have
to work that much
because you're happy it's i love it the
end
yeah and i love them too but i love my
job i love what i do
so of course and there's also moments in
time
like you know you you'll you'll get to a
place where
they'll be for three months you not
loving it as much and you're missing
your aunt and you'll spend more time
with her
that actually happened this ramadan i
believe you you know every
ramadan i have a goal of uploading at
least 20 videos okay
like 2025. this ramadan i uploaded like
seven eight videos because i wanted to
spend time with my family yeah
and people are like what's happened to
newer because like once i uploaded 30
videos in ramadan in one month have you
ever
uploaded in those scenarios of video
that says here's what's happened to me
i've been reading your comments
i just wanted to spend more time with my
family i uploaded yesterday actually
it's the best i announced our show and
then i told them i'm like i'm really
spending time with my family so that's
why i'm on
the way of it the end yeah another goal
listen this is an inside game you can do
the call
anytime you pander to anybody's voice
besides your own
it always ends up wrong that doesn't
mean not taking people's opinions
and being thoughtful but ultimately your
decisions are yours
yeah hello hey robert it's gary
vaynerchuk you're on the askgaryvee show
with me and noor
hey how's it going guys hi are you
i'm doing great what's your question
uh my question uh nora it's for you um
you know i've been in the u.s since i
was eight
uh my parents brought me here and i'm an
undocumented immigrant
i'm a dreamer and uh
i just want to thank you first for
talking out about dealing with fears of
being lonely
and i just want to know like how you
push through that fear
because i'm dealing with the fear of
hiding you know like
that's my that's how i'm successful i
hide
and i i want to break out of that you
know
do you think about that how do you think
about breaking out of things
well his his his issue
and i don't know your situation is being
a dreamer
at this point like there's still
unsettled
business in america on the dreamer
situation so
his his reality is he's gotta
play in the shadows a little bit while
things get settled
yeah that's right do it like this till
you're ready to or to like people know
by themselves that you're successful
that's what i
that's what i did like i didn't tell
anyone that i was doing social media
until they found out by themselves
and they said oh my god you're doing
this and how you're doing this
so what you're doing in my opinion is
correct because you're happy
that way you don't want people judging
you and telling you and stopping you
from doing it
so do it in the shadow until like um
to like you're ready and or like they
find out by themselves
hey robert i i'm going to take a little
bit of
i'm going to poke on this one a little
bit in a good way i think i think this
might i hope this brings you value
brother
one thing that i'm very passionate about
is not dwelling
on the reality of a situation we are
you know your reality is this is where
we are right now in the current state of
america
and how where you were born and how it
all went down
that's not something you can control and
to your point
when you're in your situation it's
fearful and you feel completely out of
control
i think remind yourself that
even people that are let's say from your
perspective fortunate that they were
born here
somebody who was born here in the last
10 minutes
had their child die in a car accident
somebody that was born here had a
million dollars stolen out of their bank
account
by their drug addict aunt and will never
get it back
somebody lost their dad somebody you
know
just got their blood work back and
they're chronically ill
in perpetuity and will be dying this
year like you know the reality is
is this is your reality and it's not fun
and i'm sure many people listening and
outside the world have lots of judgments
but this is just you in your head and
one of the things you need to play look
one of the reasons i'm super happy is
i'm always prepared
every day for my world to be shattered i
think every day
every day like what happens if everybody
that i love
dies today in a crazy accident
and in a weird way it makes me happy and
i think
i'm going to give you a left field one
but one of the things that i would do if
you're my best friend i'd probably say
this to you every day
i would say bro just make pretend every
day that you're not gonna live in
america
right you know because once that becomes
more real to you of living in canada or
denmark
or brazil or all these other wonderful
places
you know once that becomes real to you
all of a sudden the thing that feels the
scariest in the world
loses some of its teeth oh for sure
that's actually
one of the coping mech my wife and i
like she she lived in spain and that's
where she learned how to speak spanish
and that was a big connection that her
and i had that was that like
she knew spanish and then so that's what
we dream about that hey if
anything ever happens to me
go to spain you know yes and uh i just
wanted to add something i was like
my biggest fear was you know hiding and
then right after that was
anybody knowing my secret and
the way i broke through that or i'm
currently breaking through that is
three years ago i met as uh my mentor
ryan levesque
and um i went to ask live and i stood up
and i told everybody uh you know a
thousand people there that i was
undocumented
and today i'm in his new book you know
like
there's it's weird for me to know that
there are thousands of people out there
that know my secret now
well guess what good news you've now
taken back the leverage
yeah and spain's got [ __ ] amazing
wine bro
brother you've already you've already
won this game
i hope you realize it's not thousands it
actually means with internet everybody
the second you get that through your
head it's gonna get even more fun
and and that's what i'm dealing with
like the the
that fear of hiding is so intensified
because of that a hundred percent
because now you've
but this is actually no but what's
amazing is you've actually really won
what you've done is taking control it's
you you actually
were not capable of dealing with the
hiding
so you actually subconsciously exposed
yourself
which puts you in a better spot the only
thing left now is the knock on the door
that you're not looking forward to
exactly i'm aware bro listen because of
my kid you know
of course bro start getting your kids
pumped about
oh spain we we are like for real i
believe you bro
we were looking at houses bro listen to
me listen to me
the biggest thing that i'm hoping
happens during this incredible year of
openness of communication a lot of
political unrest
and a lot of dealing with truth that
society's going through
is that we it becomes one big game of
not judging others
i'm sure inevitably with what you're
going through you're probably
at the air you know you probably think
about things a little bit like i do in
some ways you're probably at
the coffee shop and you hear somebody
complaining about the dumbest [ __ ] in
the world
and you're sitting there saying i would
trade anything to be with you
switch with you so that so i wouldn't
have but what you don't know
is you think you want to switch with
that person but that person's wife dies
from a brain aneurysm the next day
i believe in what i'm saying i think a
lot of people are listening right now
and saying gary using such extremes
fine i'm using extremes you know what
scares me more
than a lot of scary things like being
undocumented or other things what about
the hidden mental health issues that
everybody on earth is walking around
with
right like we just don't know anything
about anybody else
and so all of a sudden i don't know me
thinking that everybody else has it just
as bad and just as good has kind of
weirdly eliminated my ability to judge
which has just put me in such a crazy
mental place
that i'm desperate for everybody else to
start at least flirting with
like the second you think for a second
that you wish you were somebody else
just remember you don't know jack [ __ ]
about them
right yeah no yeah actually
the first thing you said earlier that
you don't know that
you know they're here but tomorrow they
might lose their children
that was one of the things that ryan
went through uh
where he almost died and like he was
never gonna you know
he came to terms with his mortality
that's what broke me
out of my like hypnosis that my life was
shitty because that's right oh [ __ ]
i'm not dying if every person that has a
child because guess what i'd much rather
die than have my child die
if everybody in the world that has a
child actually may pretend
every day and felt it and were that
connected with themselves that they
could feel it
of the loss of their child the world
would be a much better place
totally yeah all right brother thank you
thank you let's get another call
oh i didn't understand his
i know you didn't which is why i jumped
in and helped yeah that's nice yeah i
was like
we're a team here the number you have
dialed in
i love how you like i understand talk to
me about being so big
so how many subscribers do you have on
youtube uh 11 something
okay 11.44 million talk to me about the
rest of your social media
how you thought about it did you feel
insecurity that you were so big on
youtube and not as big in other places
did that hold you back from starting
things
how have other things gone obviously you
know we've interacted a little bit on
instagram so how's that going
i was focused on youtube for the longest
time because i started on youtube and i
really love youtube yep
and then i had instagram but i never
cared like
i are shifted or archived are a lot of
pictures that it's just like random
things i used to post
and last year actually when i took
instagram seriously and i remember
you followed me a year ago i was like a
million and something or like almost two
millions and when i really focus
now i have like four point something so
i believe when you're a creative person
you can't make it
i agree and instagram is very very very
important platform
i agree has a lot of attention today
today we don't know like
if you were much older you would have
dominated myspace yeah i mean
hello austin it's garyvee you're on with
noor
hey garyvee hey nora how you guys doing
hi you're well austin what's your
question brother
oh i'm doing great i'm doing great i'm
super excited you guys called me
actually that's so awesome
happy to do it but um yeah my question
uh i
am 21 years old i actually live right
outside of seattle washington so just
like nora was saying earlier
awesome and uh i um had a question just
for gary about um what
quality content is to you when you say
that and
also um your opinion on influencer
marketing
i think influencer marketing has just
started and is nowhere close to
dying or being passe we have always
taken other people's word of mouth and i
think we are in the earliest earliest
stages
of influencer marketing and i believe
that the day i die in 100 years from now
that influencer marketing will be part
of it
because word of mouth has always been a
part of it so
early stages some will rise some will
fall quality will rise to the top
there'll be more long tail i believe
that the kids that are eight years old
now that aspire to be influenced or
marketers
may not end up getting to an organized
level but it might be a side hustle that
they always have
that every average dad every average dad
in the world
at 41 years old that's nine year olds
now will be
in play to get a 50 gift certificate or
a free item to post on their instagram
or youtube of the day
32 years from now because that's
actually how it's always work so that's
that
as far as quality brother you know
quality is completely subjective
and the audience speaks so for me it's
only the audience however
it starts with me and what i want to
make which is exactly what i was pushing
noor
about 15 to 20 minutes ago right she
knows what the audience wants
she's gotten so big now that she's only
making what the audience wants
right i know that's right and so i want
her to take the next step in her career
so now i'm trying to push her to put out
what she wants
my audience did not want by any
indication
garage sale videos my audience by any
indication
did not want baseball card videos it
didn't want parenting advice
it didn't want relationship advice it
didn't want business advice
my first five years was putting out a
video on youtube
every day of the week from 2006 to 2011
five days a week excuse me and i only
made wine videos
and the first business video i started
making people left comments saying
stay in your lane wine boy you get that
too
oh my god everybody gets that forever
yeah when you do something
for that because because i'm curious uh
you know being 21 has a really
i think that you should make yes i think
you should make a video about
every business in town
okay your real estate broker
yeah yes sir you're trying to sell
people homes in a certain area right
yeah if you become the voice that
understands every small business
every teacher that goes to the school
district and teaches the kids
every pothole on main street every
history lesson of the subway store
that's been there since 1947
if you become the social media mayor
of your area and local newspaper
of your area you will become the number
one retailer realtor
in your area you have unlimited content
bro
until you review every single business
and every single
public space and every single street and
tree and flower and teacher and
firefighter and public servant until you
interview
every single one of them you have
unlimited content
great bike man i know now the question
is are you going to execute on it
yes i you know i i listen to you a lot
gary and i appreciate it
i feel like i feel like you've said it
before too
like i've already said all this stuff
like at this point i'm just saying the
same thing over
you know until people can kind of get it
more and maybe a different piece of
content will hit people different
and that's why and that's why and that's
why i believe in access the reason i'm
giving you access to me right now
is maybe you have watched the fact that
i said be the mayor of your town
in real estate from a real estate video
in 2011 which i did
and here we are eight years later maybe
you consumed it three years ago or last
week
but the fact that you have access and
we're having this connection right now
this might be the way you need to hear
it yeah i don't get to judge
how like that's my big thing with my
audience people ask me all the time
especially
good friends inner circle they're like
bro aren't you tired of saying the same
[ __ ] like
if they don't [ __ ] get it let it
alone i'm like you're audacious
i'm like you have nothing to tell the
world i have something to tell the world
i need this
this makes me happy i want to leave a
legacy i like positive reinforcement
and if that means i have to say the same
thing until the day i die in 84 000
different ways over
800 000 different days then i will do
that because i don't get to judge how
you
consume it bro i just have to keep
putting it out in different ways and
access to the audience is one of the
biggest ways i know how
no influencer wants to do it because
it's hard it's not scalable they think
i think it's the most important
yesterday i was [ __ ] pissed three
canceled flights
had to go back through customs because i
was in [ __ ] canada and that was the
worst like you
get kicked off the plane and then you
have to wait in customs for 40 minutes
and what do i do while i'm waiting for
my car to go on instagram live and
provide more value
i also happen to be running a 200
million dollar company with a thousand
employees
yeah so anyway that's the answer brother
yeah thank you gary thank you i
appreciate it thank you
norah everybody's calling you nora does
everybody do that nora
yeah it's easier for them but my name is
noah i'm aware
yeah that's why i'm asking
right xenon do you know what i called
sanan
sinan or s seman sedan for
two and a half years oh my god and then
we were in a cardio and he's like by the
way one last thing we're having this
meeting
he goes you don't pronounce my name
right i'm like what the [ __ ] he told me
you're the first one here that
pronounced my name right
well you've got the you've yeah yeah
yeah because you're middle eastern of
course your tongue goes that way
you should see when i get going with
russian i can really [ __ ] drill it
who's this
dubai hopefully we'll connect we'll wait
a few more seconds
the number you have dialed is not in
service one more time
um did you did you get your question off
that you had written or did you have
something
we have more like okay so i have a
question that i
really like a lot of people ask it's um
what uh you say for people who have
unsupportive
parents like their parents doesn't
support them what about it yeah what
about it what's what's your advice to
them
to respectfully not listen to them
really yeah parents love their children
yeah and a lot of parents um and
especially in non-american cultures but
in america too they do it in a different
way
uh treat their kids like products yeah
and
and and also feel like their kids are a
huge reflection on them
which is where it breaks down yes but
ultimately
from what i've observed i believe that
most parents are unbelievably proud of a
child
when they are successful in not
listening to their parents
and so you win either way here's why
i'll explain in a minute
hello hello hello
it's gary how are you oh my god this is
like one of the best days of 2019
already
i love it say hello to noor hi number
hi manal how are you i'm very good
happiest
have to say mubarak in advance
hell yeah what can we what can we answer
for you
okay so one direct question so as a
woman in the middle east i
learned so hard to maintain my
sort of like no [ __ ] given attitude
because i come off as a
as a [ __ ] basically all the time when i
stand up for myself
or when i tell the truth or when i
achieve so much that people are so
scared of me and what i find happening
is that my circle keeps getting
smaller and smaller and then no one is
there to cheer on for me
stop listening to those stop listening
stop listening to those
insecure dudes yeah it's
i totally understand what you say
because i've been through the same thing
of course you gotta ignore them
and that's it you can't do anything
they're very they're just insecure i
have
i had a boy that i liked and he told me
i don't know how to deal with you
you're i don't know what to do with you
i'm 39 i'm still
single because everyone finds me you
know intimidating and i'm like
dude i would love to get with you just
give me a chance to
you know to get to know me you know i'm
not just all about the social media
bling bling
all these marathons and mountains
there's a human being behind all these
successes
look listen to both of you and to me and
to everybody the answer to all
if we're going on personal relationships
and if we're talk if we're ragging on
insecure boys which is
the dominant percentage of boys and by
the way the dominant percentage of girls
it takes two to tango right so the
reality is
to your point there you've probably
stumbled across
a ton of insecure guys who can't handle
an alpha woman
but as you know and i know hundreds of
them
let alone tens of them i know intimately
hundreds of alpha
women who have found many men who are
able to handle that so what i would say
is a couple things
one of course there's a staggering
amount of people that are insecure and
can't deal with an alpha woman
by the way there's a lot of women that
can't handle alpha guys even though it's
more common
and we see that we all look at that
however
you also have to be thoughtful about if
you're at a place
now it just you listen you come across
from me from afar and even
the way you're even talking right now
the biggest question you have to figure
out is
how happy or unhappy are you about it
one of the things that i think is going
to become a very fascinating
conversation over the next century
is does one need to become
married right like like my biggest
question for you is
how happy are you right now
that's the question yes you are
i'm very very um like proud of my
achievements but then they do not take
the society arab society's boxes and
that's why sometimes i feel unhappy
like you know i always say when i share
i think you'll be finishing a marathon
or climbing a mountain and uh what's up
groove to my mom
i get it i don't receive my response i
don't even say well done
you don't even get it listen let me
frame let me freeze another
no you're right listen let me phrase i
don't get it because i'm not a middle
eastern woman
and but back i get it of course you do
because you guys could connect them
thank you but you'll appreciate this and
i think this is something we all have to
do
none of us get the other person if you
don't go through that experience but
that goes for everybody
the reason i get it i'm gonna say it
again this is a very micro thing
nor listen to me i am 43 years old yeah
in 1985 18 1989 1992 when you got d's
and f's
the entire world said you were a [ __ ]
loser
yeah there wasn't a single person kids
don't grow up with that now
now there's entrepreneurship yeah so so
like my whole life has been
misunderstood
most do do you ladies know that almost
everybody in the advertising world the
business i'm in
thinks i'm a charlatan and completely
full of [ __ ]
like like everybody has pushback i
when i'm called a charlatan or snake oil
salesman have to be thoughtful of
do they have any point i process it
and then i move on and i think what you
need to think about
is listen nobody will ever convince me
that there's not one
you could tell me 98 of people see it
that way
but you will never convince me because
i've seen it too many times there's
always one
what are you doing about it to put
yourself in a position to find that one
is the biggest thing that you can focus
on really
you can't focus on other people nobody
else i have no interest in convincing or
forcing anyone else to be
anything i focus on myself and then i
say yes or no
based on me and that's what you need to
do in this scenario
yeah and don't let the pressure make you
make
wrong decisions you know sure that's the
most important thing
yeah i mean look you know just find it
very hard to stay on track with all
these people telling your negative [ __ ]
them
like i'm getting [ __ ] up [ __ ] them
[ __ ] them like like and by the way if
you're
str if anybody's listening and they're
struggling with that
that's on you it's [ __ ] them comma get
your [ __ ] together
yeah like living your life based on
other people's opinions
is the quickest way to live an unhappy
life
yes and and when you're and when you
have audiences like the three of us do
you can't take the good without the bad
you love the positive reinforcement you
love the comments that say you're the
greatest and you change their life
you then have to accept that people are
gonna say you're a piece of [ __ ]
that's the cost of the [ __ ] game yeah
and that's how i do it
listen like like you know like all of us
are being
judged and and in different times and
different spaces
i'm i'm very similar genetically to my
great grandfather right
he just happened to be born in soviet
russia as a jewish man
which meant he was ridiculed and beat up
and put in jail for
11 years i
was born in america where i didn't have
to deal with that so obviously i have a
different scenario and obviously we're
different i'm sure
no two are the same but we can only deal
with
our realities there you know there's no
changing our realities
what you need to focus on is none of the
outside
and only on the inside put yourself in a
position to find what you're looking for
instead of dwelling on what the outside
is not giving you
100 500 thank you gary you understand
because
every second you think oh my culture
doesn't get it oh these guys
don't get it oh that boy i like doesn't
get it every second
you're spending on that you're not
spending on getting what you want
you're wasting your time and if you
think he doesn't get it then that's it
he's gone don't waste your time on him
you know what i find something like we
waste a lot of time
thinking that it's going to work and
it's not going to work when they tell
you
or like they show signs that it's not
going to work that's it the [ __ ] out
x and then next you move on with your
life and that's how you don't waste your
time and not
it's having conviction without being
delusional yeah
stick to your guns but make sure you're
listening to the feedback i always think
i'm right
until enough people tell me i'm wrong
not a couple
yeah but what's enough like how much is
enough though like how do you quantify
that
enough is when a bunch of people that
don't have any vested
interest have a thought and i respect
their thought like the reality is
for me enough is like almost everybody
like
thousands you know because otherwise i'm
gonna stick to my guns i think the
the bigger question though that's three
more of a business answer in
relationship answers
it's one every time i sense my whole
life that
somebody wasn't interested in me i
didn't spend any time on it
yes i i'll be very honest with you i
never chased a single girl
because i'm like because i was like
excited and i mean this because i was
i was like no but i but but
but everybody sees everybody sees the
end nobody saw the process
nobody in my high school or college
thought i was going to be gary vee
i thought i was going to be and that's
the point
yes that's the [ __ ] point yes you
know how much happiness i have
that every girl that ever knew that i
had some interest that didn't have
interest
now has to deal with the ramifications
it's yeah it's a delicious taste all
right i gotta get out of here thanks for
the call
noor i adore you you get to ask the
question of the day what question do you
have for the audience
for the audience yes oh my god if uh
what's stopping you from following your
dream like the dream that you really
want to do
what's stopping you and i never jump in
on question today as my team knows but
you just had such a great
question and it was such a great podcast
show episode
tell the truth even if you have to
create a fake account
so your parents or sibling or spouse or
children don't see it
create a fake account a burner and tell
the truth
actually saying the truth out loud
impacts humans tremendously
yeah thank you so much thank you thank
you such a pleasure you were amazing
you keep asking questions we'll keep
answering them
the incredible nor stops by on today's
episode
awesome oh my god that was amazing